unless you've been living under a rock
odds are you've at least heard about
Bitcoin with prices skyrocketing in
recent months numbers like $20,000 have
piqued the interest of even the least
tech-savvy individuals you've probably
had an older relative ask you what the
heck is going on with the magic internet
money in this video we're not going to
get bogged down with all the technical
details there are plenty of other
excellent videos for that already some
of which you can find linked in the
description
instead use this video as a kind of
jumping-off point a place to start your
adventures in the world of crypto and
consider whether it's something you
should be invested in let's start with
the biggest question for most people
what is it to answer that we'll start
with a little history back in 2008 an
anonymous figure going by the name
Satoshi Nakamoto announced the release
of his invention a decentralized
peer-to-peer digital cash system this
was the beginning of Bitcoin Satoshi had
seen numerous centralized digital
currency projects fail and by opting for
a peer-to-peer system he managed to
create the very first cryptocurrency
instead of relying on banks to keep
transactions honest and prevent double
spending crypto currencies like Bitcoin
rely on what's called the blockchain on
the blockchain everyone sending and
receiving money has access to a public
ledger basically a list of global
transactions in order to make sure
future transactions aren't an attempt to
spend money that isn't there it sounds
weird and techy but it's actually pretty
simple imagine you're at a party and
you're betting on a game no one brought
cash so you all decide to keep track of
bets on your own individual sheets of
paper after each round everyone compares
their records with so many copies of
transactions any discrepancies would be
obvious and everyone is kept honest
for example if Steve says I only bet 5
bucks that round everyone else could
check their records and either verify or
challenge that claim that's the
blockchain in a nutshell this system
circumvents the need for a central bank
allowing truly peer-to-peer transactions
and minimal transaction fees ok but
what's a Bitcoin or litecoin or ether
and why are there so many different
currencies
here's the technical definition a
cryptocurrency is a digital medium of
exchange created and stored
electronically in the blockchain using
encryption techniques to control the
creation of monetary units and verify
the transfer of fun
it has no intrinsic value no physical
form and its supply is not determined by
a central bank think of the actual coins
like your online bank account
you see credit and debit transactions
and your current balance you can take a
debit card to the store and buy
something you don't need to have
physical cash the bank verifies you have
the money to spend and you get your
product bitcoin is the same way except
instead of a bank approving the
transaction it's the blockchain and just
like you measure foreign currencies
against your country's currency other
coins are usually measured against
Bitcoin and you can exchange them for
one another just like traditional
currencies as for why there are so many
different Kryptos or coins typically
each one represents a new technology and
development and when you buy some amount
of any given crypto you're supporting
that technology for example when you buy
Tron coins you're supporting that team's
goal of creating a block chain based
free content entertainment system that
enables users to publish and store data
when you buy electro neum you support
the goal of making cryptocurrency more
accessible to the average smartphone
user and the people who don't want to
get in over their heads with mining and
all the technical stuff each coin serves
a purpose and many people choose to
invest in the technology that they'd
like to see become mainstream of course
many other people just see the dollar
signs and that's ok too
there are plenty of stories of early
adopters buying Bitcoin when it was dirt
cheap and are now multi millionaires the
cryptocurrency market is booming and
people are flooding in trying to find
the next coin to explode an interesting
aspect of the crypto boom is that
investors are mostly young rather than
the older demographic which typically
has more disposable income to risk
trends indicate that this is well on its
way to changing with many expecting a
surge of new investors from all walks of
life within the next year so the big
question should you invest in
cryptocurrency well that's a question
you'll have to answer yourself but here
are some tips number one don't make any
investments thinking you'll be a
millionaire in a year you could be if
you invest enough and wisely but you
could also lose it all the crypto market
is incredibly volatile often compared to
the stock market on fast-forward as
currency values experience huge swings
on daily or weekly timeframes number two
never invest more than you can afford to
lose if 10 bucks and a promising coin is
all you can afford just invest the 10
dollars you
you can buy tiny fractions of coins you
don't need to spend tens of thousands in
order to get in on Bitcoin number three
do your research don't just go in
blindly find the white paper for each
coin you like and read it understand
what you're investing in you'd be amazed
how many people just throw money into
coins without knowing what they're for
okay so you decide to jump in what are
the first steps you'll need a count on a
few sites coin base is a good place to
start though it does have relatively
high transaction fees it's a very easy
way to buy a few of the biggest coins
namely Bitcoin and aetherium but wait
what if I don't want Bitcoin don't worry
you can exchange your Bitcoin for
whatever coins you like next you'll want
to bookmark coin market cap to keep
track of coin prices and only buy when
the price is right the next step is to
make an account on an exchange like
finance cracking or crypto PIA not all
coins are available on all exchanges so
you may want to set up an account on
several on these sites you can set your
exchange pair for example Bitcoin to XRP
but before you buy your coins you'll
want to download a wallet for whatever
currency you choose there are various
mobile apps to store some currencies but
many smaller coins require a specific
wallet for the time being to stick with
the ripple example you can download rip
X wallet and set up your account follow
the instructions very carefully you
don't want your information to get lost
and lose access to your coins once
you've got your wallet set up you can
exchange your Bitcoin and deposit your
new coins into your wallet there are
slight differences between how you buy
different coins and ways to dodge
transaction fees but there are plenty of
excellent tutorials on those subjects
which I'll provide in the description
along with links to all the sites
mentioned over the course of this video
the world of cryptocurrency is
fascinating and exciting and there will
be lots of world-changing new
technologies and plenty of new
millionaires made in the coming decade
if the boom is truly just beginning as
with anything involving money be careful
do your research and know why you're
investing there are great communities on
reddit dedicated to different coins and
crypto as a whole so make sure you drop
in and learn from the pros if you do
decide to invest let me know your top
picks in the comments below who knows
maybe we'll all pick the right coin that
turns out to be bitcoin 2.0 if you
enjoyed this video consider subscribing
to support the channel and click the
little bell to be notified every time I
release a new video you can watch my
previous video by clicking here
or if you're really bored you can binge
watch all my content by clicking here
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next week